well a streaker was a difficult one for
the government forced into to you turns
in the space of three days where one of
those was on child refugees from Europe
with the Prime Minister facing a
rebellion from his own backbenchers
agreeing to accept unaccompanied
children from Europe Scouts it's a
subject on which the SNP's Westminster
leader Angus Robertson has been leading
the charge and he joins me now from
elgin and a very good morning to you and
just let me ask you about that it's been
said you've heard it before I I know
that the the SNP in Westminster is that
is the real opposition and particularly
honor on an issue like that are you
rather filling I suppose the the void
left by Labour beset with all its
troubles well very good mornings from
sunny speyside and yes the SNP is the
effective opposition at Westminster the
Labour Party is spending more time
fighting each other than fighting the
Tories and there a whole series of
issues that matter to voters in Scotland
but across the rest of the United
Kingdom to from austerity at to issues
like how we deal with refugees and on
these that's the SNP that's been leading
the charge and we will continue to do so
we've got big decisions coming up
shortly on remaining within the European
Union or being taken out against our
will or whether we're going to waste the
best part of two hundred billion pounds
replacing weapons of mass destruction on
these issues the SNP will be battling on
austerity on Europe on Trident and
trying to make sure that the the Tories
do not cut away from the public services
that really matter across the UK and and
evolved Scotland where we now have that
straight fight between the SNP reelected
to government and the Tory opposition
yeah but I mean is it the fact then that
inadvertently because of the analysis
you've given us there at the state of
play in Westminster that the stays are
becoming loosened as it were on that SNP
self-denying ordinance that you didn't
get involved in Affairs that didn't
affect Scotland well we always said that
where we could forge a progressive
majority in Westminster add that we
would do that but there are issues that
have come along which have actually
impacted in Scotland so let's take
sunday trading as an example
which people say oh well this is only a
proposal that was going to impact in
England well no it wasn't because the
government gave no safeguards to the
knock-on consequences to workers in
Scotland so that would have been a
retrograde step and that's why we
signaled that we would be opposing the
government on that and it caused them to
you turn on their plans similarly on
issues like the refugee question because
a sustained opposition yes from the SNP
but from others to goodness me Alf dubs
in the House of Lords Yvette Cooper from
the Labour Party there are people right
across a house in including
conservatives who don't like much which
the Tories are actually doing so where
we can we will work with others the
government of Westminster only has a
majority of 12 often on an issue by
issue basis they won't have a majority
at all and the SNP will work
constructively with other parties at
Westminster to oppose the Tories a
Nicola Sturgeon reelected as at First
Minister shortly in the Scottish
Parliament what a fantastic result that
was with the SNP vote going up and is
actually having more MSPs members of the
Scottish Parliament than the next three
parties combined we will work with other
parties wasn't register under the
Scottish Parliament to try and get the
best well indeed that's the way that the
electoral system works curious isn't it
yes we won more seats in the
constituencies we won more votes than
any political party has ever won in the
Scottish Parliament but because we have
a proportional system it gave us the it
gave us a result that we got which saw
us getting as i say more than all of the
next three parties added together but
there's still a pro-independence
majority in the scottish parliament and
so we will fight for the best deal there
and deliver the best in terms of public
services and reform to our public
services and at the same time at
Westminster we will oppose the Tories
tooth and nail and work is the effective
opposition not just on issues that
matter directly to people in Scotland
but also the rest of the UK and on
matters such as Europe and International
Affairs who are sadly the Labour Party
has taken its eye of the ball just want
to get back well that's just want to get
back to that issue in Westminster there
and see it through the focus that very
important issue of child refugees and
you mentioned there the Labour figures
who were involved on that issue if at
cooper and lord dubs of course lay
a table that amendment but mr. Corbett
didn't ask any questions about it at the
last session of Prime Minister's
Questions do you think jeremy corbyn's
pretty useless well on this issue yes on
others perhaps less so but often i am
SAT there cuz i get as the SNP leader at
westminster i get two questions every
week and of course have to follow jeremy
corbyn and i sit there often think on
earth is he asking about it's not the
issue of the day it's not the issue of
the week and this refugee question is a
classic for the last two weeks it's what
I've been raising as the SNP leader at
Westminster he hasn't it's come from the
Labour backbenchers from the likes of a
vet Cooper and so on the issues that
matter often it's the SNP which is
raising them and I will continue to do
that what Jeremy Corbyn decides to ask
is up to him I know many voters around
the country are asking what are the
questions that he is asking and of
course the results for the Labour Party
with the Honorable exception of Sadiq
cannon in London who I congratulate and
note with horror the nature of the dog
whistle campaign that the Tories run in
London but back to Westminster we will
take our opportunities to ask the things
that really matters to people here and
the rest of the UK if the labour party
once continue to miss the ball week
after week that's up to them but will
continue to be the effective opposition
that's what we were sent there to do
that is what will continue to do what do
you think that I mean I'm interested do
you think that that Labour tripping over
in front front of the goal as as you
tell me there could ultimately have an
impact on the timing of another
independence referendum in Scotland in
that progressive thinkers in Scotland
even some of them who currently support
the union may think well listen we're
never going to see another Labour
government we've got to get out of this
union well this is a huge part of the
the interest and the realignment of what
is going on in Scottish politics am so
not only a year ago to the SNP when
almost every single constituency in
Scotland and the Labour Party being
almost wiped dead only holding one seat
that's exactly what happened this time
the SNP winning almost all of the
constituency seats the Labour Party
losing almost all of theirs if you were
a Labour voter who has
stuck with the Labor Party in Scotland
for thick and thin you must be asking
yourself why are we run by a party the
Tories who I have only one seat in
Scotland at Westminster and had pulled
just over twenty percent how long can
this go on and I'm sure the longer it
goes on and if there were to be a relay
in reelected Tory government the next UK
election mean does anybody really think
that Jeremy Corbyn is going to be the
next British Prime Minister I don't
think so and for that reason I think a
lot of people in Scotland as you suggest
it will ask themselves how long can this
go on for another's question about
whether and when there will be an
independence referendum and Scott stood
up to politicians it's not up to the SNP
it's certainly not up to the Tories to
say to people in Scotland they can't
have one people want one and if they
want independence that's up to them
nobody should stand in their way people
don't want that at the present time the
polls have shifted in the direction of
independence but it's not a majority yet
and there isn't a demand for that
referendum to take place yet but if that
should happen whenever that is that's
exactly what will happen but it could
change pretty quickly couldn't it I mean
if the UK votes to leave the European
Union you'd have one literally spit well
if we're taken again out to the European
Union against our will that's a material
change in circumstances Pete voters in
Scotland were told to vote against gotta
shoot air independence as a way of
staying within the European Union and
should it come about that were taken out
whilst voting to remain in that'll make
a whole lot of people think while the
games are bogie now do I want that
circumstance no i do not want the United
Kingdom to leave the EU and take
Scotland I don't want that so I'll be
campaigning to remain within the EU I
would prefer if and when the people in
Scotland want to have a referendum that
we can do that on its own merits and
people are convinced on the basis of the
positive ideas the positive reasons for
independence or the positive reasons to
remain within the UK as opposed to the
project for your nonsense we had in 2014
and frankly which we're hearing a lot of
in the European referendum now that is
what I hope for in the future but it is
the people in a democracy who are in the
driving seat and in the meantime the SNP
will continue to be the effective
opposition fighting day-to-day
week-to-week on the issues that matter
at Westminster and
polish parliament re-elected historic
third term SNP government with Nicola
Sturgeon as First Minister prepared to
work across the parties and
constructively that is how we will
approach things I think that's what the
public like and for that reason I think
the support for independence will go up
because they'll see the alternative is
continuing Tory austerity being governed
by a party we haven't even elected that
frankly thinks it can do whatever it
likes in Scotland well I think the the
time will come when people in spotless
said we've had enough of this mr.
Robertson great talking to you Angus
Robertson their the SNP's Westminster
leader